There's so much to discover on Netflix, ranging
from action to horror to science fiction and
beyond. Sometimes finding the perfect movie for
your mood can be tough. Not to worry, we're here
to help and we've spotlighted some hidden Netflix
gems that you can add to your must-watch list.
Fashion designer Tom Ford scripted
and directed Nocturnal Animals,
a mind-bending, and deeply unsettling thriller
in which the plot itself blends, interferes,
and gets confused with a story being told by the
film's troubled characters. Amy Adams plays Susan,
an unhappily married art gallery owner who
receives a fascinating novel manuscript called
Nocturnal Animals, written by her vindictive
first husband, Edward, played by Jake Gyllenhaal.
The action in the film shifts to depict the book,
a horrifying story about Tony, also portrayed by
Gyllenhaal, a man whose car breaks down in rural
Texas just before a gang of criminals kidnaps his
wife and daughter and leaves him stranded. It's
up to Detective Bobby Andes, a strong-but-silent
type to help Tony exact his revenge.
Meanwhile, back in Susan and Edward's world,
viewers learn about the emotional devastation
that led to the demise of their marriage.
Neil Pond of Parade called Nocturnal Animals an...
"Arty and grotesquely gorgeous, but
hardly an uplifting tale. [...] Think
No Country For Old Men meets CSI:
West Texas, by way of Twin Peaks."
Jason Momoa looks like a superhero in real life,
so it's logical he gets to play larger-than-life
figures like Aquaman and physical characters
like Khal Drogo on Game of Thrones. These
roles seem like a natural fit for Momoa.
"I dig it."
In Braven, Momoa gets the opportunity
to play a regular guy for once. Albeit,
a regular guy thrust into a stressful
situation and forced to do heroic things.
A humble family man named Joe Braven
takes his father and daughter to
their cabin in the woods to forget
their troubles for a couple of days.
Unfortunately, they don't get any rest
and relaxation because they run afoul
of drug traffickers who have been using
the Braven's property as a stash house.
A violent and bloody standoff ensues as Braven
fights to protect his property and his family.
Joe Leydon of Variety
perfectly summed up the film…
"To put it simply and gratefully, Braven
is the sort of unpretentious yet thoroughly
professional popcorn entertainment that
brings out the best in everybody involved."
A Monster Calls might
sound like the name of a horror movie, but it's
actually a Spielberg-like fantasy. Director J.A.
Bayona crafts an allegorical, eye-popping film
about all-too real and difficult emotions from
the point of a view of a child, which makes it all
the more heartbreaking. A Monster Calls is about
grief, but it's also about a walking, talking,
tree creature with the voice of Liam Neeson.
Conor is 13, and his mother is dying. He's
just old enough to know what's going on,
but young enough to have no idea how to cope;
he can't turn to his stern grandmother for help
and his father isn't a big part of his life.
An unlikely and impossible ally arrives just when
Conor needs him: He is the Monster, a massive,
sentient yew tree who offers to tell Conor three
grand tales. After that, Conor must share his own.
"Stories are wild creatures, Conor O'Malley.
When you let them loose, who
know what havoc they may wreak?"
It's all a little frightening and also
wonderful, and the revelation of where
the tree learned his stories will definitely
leave the viewer misty-eyed, which is rare
for a movie about a giant monster who may or
may not be a figment of a child's imagination.
Television has been graced with many reality and
game shows that pit a group of strangers against
each other, requiring a vote to eliminate all but
one last-standing champion. Alliances are formed,
but it's ultimately every person for themselves.
The provocative and frightening 2015 film Circle
takes the idea and ups the stakes considerably. 50
strangers, all facing execution, are placed in a
darkened room and made to choose among themselves
which one of them shall get to walk out alive.
"It's us."
"Us?"
"What do you mean?"
"We're choosing who dies."
The sparse film's sparse 87
minutes fly by as various unnamed,
desperate characters passionately
argue and bargain on behalf of their
own futures while time and chances run out.
Of course, they also have to fear immediate
eradication by the wicked forces holding
them in the room if they so much as move.
John DeFore of The Hollywood Reporter
wrote about the film, saying...
"[Circle] keeps suspense alive, building
to a final tableau that, silently,
says nearly as much about human nature
as does all the talk leading up to it."
At the beginning of Elizabeth Harvest, the film
seems like an examination of a newlywed couple's
life. Henry and Elizabeth Kellenberg appear to be
delicately adjusting to life as married people.
Elizabeth moves into the wealthy and prominent
Henry's beautiful, well-appointed home
filled with luxuries and creature comforts.
In the spirit of their new partnership,
Henry gives Elizabeth free rein over his
house, and suggests that they'll live in
wedded bliss so long as she doesn't go poking
around one mysterious room in the basement.
"That sounds ominous."
Naturally, Elizabeth can't help herself and
investigates the forbidden zone. This is when the
film takes a turn and gets really interesting. She
discovers a shocking secret that sends her down a
mysterious path filled with danger and intrigue.
With elements of science fiction and horror,
Elizabeth Harvest is a dark fairytale
that explores man's darkest impulses.
War movies are,
by their nature, action movies. The best ones
re-create true events with emotional honesty
and visceral realism that exposes viewers to an
approximation of the nightmarish world of combat.
The Outpost is such a movie, taking place during
the Battle of Kamdesh, a crucial, and deadly
2009 event in the ongoing Afghanistan War. At the
Keating combat outpost, set in a valley of three
mountains, outnumbered American soldiers fight
an onslaught of well-armed Taliban combatants.
Presented as a series of episodes, The
Outpost doesn't just re-create an epic
battle from recent history, but it tells
a story which allows the audience to get
to know the characters. The members of the
troop are mostly just regular, decent people
thrust into a difficult and clearly terrifying
situation, with everything leading up to the
can't-look-away battle scenes. In fact, Matt
Fowler of IGN described The Outpost as...
"A cleverly, and respectfully, crafted war film."
Knock Knock is a home invasion thriller with a
couple of twists. The criminals have an important,
if cynical, lesson to teach about the
baseness of men, and it's also one of
the few movies where the universally beloved
Keanu Reeves plays an unlikeable character.
This dread-inducing and quick-moving 2015
thriller from writer-director Eli Roth
begins innocuously with a knock on the door
of the beautiful home of seemingly happily
married architect Evan Webber. Because of work
obligations, he's home alone, with his dog,
Monkey, over Father's Day while
his family takes a quick vacation.
Genesis and Bel, two young, flirtatious women,
played by Lorenza Izzo and a pre-Knives Out
Ana de Armas, gain entry, claiming to
be lost and looking for a house party.
"Not everyone would just let two total
strangers into their house these days."
"Well, you don't look that dangerous."
The women aggressively come on to
Evan, and he eventually gives in to
his base carnal urges — and that's
when the terror and violence begin.
Knock Knock is actually a light
remake of the 1977 B-movie Death Game,
which has gained a cult following in the years
since its release. Just like the original,
this film is packed with thrills, suspense,
humor and over-the-top performances.
An elite squad of secret operatives
hunting down and punishing those who committed
unspeakable acts of terror against their community
is a small film genre unto itself — and
a good one at that. Among such stories,
one can find as much action and drama as cathartic
psychology and shocking real-world history.
In the same vein of Steven Spielberg's Munich,
which told the story of Israeli Mossad agents
going after the terrorists who killed athletes at
the 1972 Summer Olympics, comes Operation Finale.
The film details the early '60s mission
of a team of highly-trained, top secret
Israeli operatives who travel to Argentina
in order to bring to justice Adolf Eichmann.
He was a high-ranking Nazi official who
masterminded the logistics of the Holocaust,
responsible for the deaths of millions
of Jewish people. Oscar Isaac plays
real-life Mossad agent Peter Malkin,
leading the charge against Eichmann.
M.V. Moorhead of Phoenix
Magazine called Operation Finale…
"Crisp and absorbing and satisfying,
both as a thriller and as a moral drama."
On one level, viewers know exactly what
they're getting when they click on a
movie called Vampires vs. the Bronx.
"We got vampires in the Bronx."
It is indeed a violent tale of creepy
bloodsuckers hailing from Eastern Europe,
in the classic vampire movie style. But this
time, they're in a modern-day urban setting,
specifically one of New York City's five boroughs.
However, Vampires vs. the Bronx is so much more
than that — it's a socially conscious celebration
of Bronx culture, the story of a bunch of smart
and capable kids coming together to save the
day, and a deeply satirical horror-comedy.
The vampiric real estate agents at the center
of the story represent wealthy individuals
and businesses that want to
gentrify older neighborhoods,
and a scrappy bunch of young people have to stop
them before nothing is left and no one is alive.
"Don't go there, Ma."
"He's...he's a really bad man."
"Of course he is, he's in real estate."
Like many critics, Ben Travis
of Empire had positive things
to say about Vampires vs. the
Bronx. He called the film...
"A witty and likable horror-comedy that manages to
put a stake to the heart of some real
issues while it tickles your ribs."
Based on Joe Ballarini's series of gently
spooky kids novels of the same name,
The Babysitter's Guide to Monster Hunting is a
family-friendly movie directed by Rachel Talalay,
a filmmaker best known for her work on Tank
Girl and the Nightmare on Elm Street series.
Ballarini and Talalay were the ideal combo to
make what could be a kid's first horror-comedy,
a dark, funny, and twisted take on the
'80s classic Adventures in Babysitting.
Teenage babysitter Kelly gets a gig looking after
a kid on Halloween night. That's a bummer in and
of itself, made worse when the child is kidnapped
by the actual Boogeyman. Kelly has to do her best
to rescue the little guy. Luckily, she's helped
along the way in her fight against monsters,
goblins, and pure evil by a secret society
of elite and well-equipped babysitters.
"Ugh, I hate babysitters."
Nell Minnow of Movie Mom said the film delivers...
"Gorgeously imagined settings, a great cast,
and an exciting story that hits the exact sweet
spot between funny-scary and scary-funny."
The 12th Man is a war movie, a
survival tale, and, amazingly,
it's also a true story. Jan Baalsrud worked for
the Norwegian resistance during Nazi Germany's
occupation of his country during World War II.
Trained as a commando by the British military,
Baalsrud attempts an escape to neutral Sweden
following a sabotage mission gone wrong. To get to
freedom, he has to face the punishing weather of
Scandinavia in the winter. The Norway-based Nazis,
however, notice almost immediately that Baalsrud
has disappeared and chase him through the icy
mountains, where conditions are so severe that
frostbite and hypothermia may claim him first.
Among many other positive reviews, Frank
Sheck of The Hollywood Reporter wrote...
"The 12th Man proves consistently
engrossing and suspenseful,
with its lead performances
further enhancing its impact."
The best horror movies consist of a
lot more than just a few jump scares
and some terrifying form of bone-chilling
menace — the good ones reflect and comment
upon the everyday things that trouble human
beings. Little Evil is that kind of movie.
It's a horror-comedy, with the emphasis on comedy,
about an eager-to-please guy who marries a
woman who has a son from a previous marriage.
He's desperate to connect with the inscrutable
little guy so his relationship can thrive and they
can all come together as a happy family. That's a
difficult task, as the kid is actually the spawn
of Satan and he's not afraid to unleash pure evil
and terror on his well-meaning new stepdad. And
that's where the horror comes into play; that,
and with a creepy hand-puppet named Reeroy.
"I'm your step-father now."
"Get out."
"Yeah, okay. We'll just talk
later or whenever you want."
Amanda Sink of The Hollywood Outsider
perfectly described the film in one line.
"Little Evil is [The] Omen
by way of Shaun of the Dead."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
movies on Netflix are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.